Teresa Giudice says her husband Joe
watches Bravo from prison they love
Bravo they're okay
[Music]
on Wednesday the Real Housewives of New
Jersey star stopped by watch what
happens live with Andy Cohen
and revealed that her hubby has TV
privileges behind bars he watches us in
the hall all the time
no way Wow they love Bravo there okay a
juicy job last week Joe's brother-in-law
Joe Gorga was on the late-night show and
a dish that the 45 year old former
reality star was also getting fit in the
slammer he lost 40 45 pounds
Teresa confirmed he looks like you the
mother of four also had a message for
her man noting that he was probably
tuning in to watch hi honey love you
mwah
Joe is currently serving a 41 month
prison sentence which began in March of
2016
the couple pleaded guilty to fraud
charges in 2014 but requested to serve
jail time separately to ensure their
daughters have parental care Teresa
opened up to et in 2016 about how her
man was coping behind bars
[Music]